foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to show you what another
one of the Game of Thrones actors had to
say about HBO's new Game of Thrones
series House of the Dragon now if you're
someone who watches all of my videos
then you know I've already made a few of
these before in other interviews
regarding House of the Dragon we've
heard what Amelia Maisie and even Mr
Harrington have had to say about the new
show although most of the Game of
Thrones actors were very excited about
seeing another show set in Westeros some
of them also knew how hard it is for a
spin-off show to find success I mean
let's be honest most of these shows
never do now that house of the Dragon
has aired four of its episodes from its
first season it's already looking like
this new show is making its own name for
itself even a lot of the fans who hated
the Game of Thrones finale who also said
they would never watch another series
set in the world of Ice and Fire seem to
be enjoying the show as you all know
this is amazing news for HBO and also
Song of Ice and Fire fans because it
opens the door for all the other shows
that are in development if you know me
and you watch all of my videos then you
already know I'm hoping the Jon Snow
series will be given the green light
next now before House of the Dragon
aired on HBO and before we knew there
was a Jon Snow show in development Mr
Harrington gave some of his thoughts
about the new show focusing on House
Targaryen when he was interviewed by
Insider he revealed that it might be
hard for him to watch the new show he
was very open about how much he loved
working on the original show and how
much he would miss being in Westeros
himself his love for Game of Thrones and
this universe seems very obvious now
that we know he wants to give Jon Snow a
more fitting ending in this new
interview he revealed he is watching
House of the dragon and he also said how
he feels about it to tell me are you
watching House of dragon I am yeah I'm
really enjoying it yeah my friend Miguel
show ran it so
um I'm really enjoying it I think
they've done a fantastic job it's a it's
a weird one to start a whole new show in
the same kind of Realm and and to make
it its own thing and I think that
they've they've really done that yeah
now it is very interesting to hear him
say it is weird starting a whole new
show in the same kind of Realm while
making it its own thing because as we
all know he is developing a show that
will basically do the same thing he has
first-hand knowledge on just how weird
it must be to dive back into Westeros
without having all of those same
legendary characters we've all grown to
love with that being said although we
last Saw Jon Snow in the far north he
could always come South again and
reunite with the characters that are
still alive hopefully we'll find out
more about his own show soon enough as
always I will let all of you know
whenever I find out more information
make sure you subscribe so you're the
first to know whenever I drop a new
video in regards to Game of Thrones
House of the dragon or anything else
involving the amazing Universe of A Song
of Ice and Fire for now have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign